-Our next guest is
an Emmy Award-winning writer
and actress
you know from her work
on "Saturday Night Live"
and the shows
"Mapleworth Murders"
and "Girls5eva."
She stars in "A.P. Bio," which
is streaming now on Peacock.
Let's take a look.
-Did a tornado really kill
your grandfather?
-My grandfathers.
It killed both of them.
They went out to distract it.
So me and my meemaws could
get in the root cellar.
And it scooped 'em up
and slammed 'em together
like a pair of dirty flip-flops.
And then I turned back to look.
They popped like two water
balloons full of SpaghettiOs.
They popped my pop-pops!
And now, it's coming back
to get me, to finish the job.
-Please welcome back to the show
one of the funniest people
on the planet, our very good
friend Paula Pell.
Hello, Paula!
-Hi!
-It's so good to see you.
You're looking resplendent.
You are looking dressed the way
an Emmy-nominated actress
should look.
-Well, thank you so much.
I wanted to zip up my Zoom
and just wear a little bit of
sparkles for you, and I feel --
I can't believe we're having
such an orthopedic episode of
your show,
because of Amanda
with her pickleball shoulder,
and I just got
a knee replacement
because I have B.J. knee.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm so -- I'm so sorry.
That just got diagnosed?
-I only kneel on one knee.
It's very formal when I do it.
It's very seldom I do it,
I'm gonna be honest.
-I think that's
the British style, right?
One knee? That's a BBJ?
[ Laughter ]
-This also is the start of an
homage to Broadway coming back,
which I'm so excited about,
and also my favorite
New York memory, which was
going into therapy one time
and some man coming down
the stairs from this building.
And he had sort of
a sparkle scarf on,
and he clearly had been
at voice lessons.
And he was in the hall,
which had good acoustics,
and he was singing...
♪ Give them
the old razzule dazzule ♪
[ Laughter ]
And it was clear to me that
the teacher had told him
that he was swallowing
his vowels, you know?
Because in choir they tell you,
like, "razzle, drazzle, dazzle."
You have to ♪ razzle, dazzle ♪
You create space in there.
-Now, did you -- when you were
looking for a therapist,
did you try to find one
that was in a building
with a voice coach?
-You know, in New York,
you don't have a choice.
[ Laughter ]
You might be in there
and someone's cooking pierogies
next door.
[ Laughter ]
It's just -- there's a --
There's just a weird amalgam of
people in New York apartments.
-I want to point out
that your Emmy nomination
is for "Mapleworth Murders."
There you are with
also Emmy-nominated
and "Late Night" writer
John Lutz.
-John Lutz.
-And so exciting that
"A.P. Bio" is back.
Helen is one of my favorite
characters on TV.
An optimist. Wouldn't you
describe her as an optimist?
-Yes, an optimist.
I love doing Helen.
She reminds me a lot of
my Midwestern roots of my --
of all the -- similar to
the South, of women that smile
and completely lie to you.
And so, my grandma, you know,
she just always was
full of enthusiasm and cheer,
and then you'd get
little moments of truth.
Like she used to --
we used to -- I used to take her
to a little diner called
the Pine Cone.
"Oh, God, and how, let's go to
the Pine Cone."
We'd go to the Pine Cone
and get soup.
Raviolis, they'd call them,
which is like tortellini soup.
"Oh, is this soup ever good!
Oh, and how!"
And she'd call the manager over
to specifically tell him
how good the soup is.
She had her little saltines.
"Oh, this soup is j--
and the broth, oh, my God."
And then we'd leave,
and in the parking lot,
she'd go,
"I didn't care for that soup."
[ Laughter ]
'Cause, you know, so Helen has
that, like, very dark underbelly
that we're seeing more and more
in each season,
where she's kind of full of it,
in terms of her --
you know, she's a very
suppressed, more dark soul
that's always laced in cheer,
because that keeps her
wanting to live.
-We have certainly been
enjoying the journey.
And then a really fun thing
that happened this year
is your real-life wife, Janine,
played one of Helen's hook-ups.
That must have been both nice
and then it actually happened
on another show this year.
-Yes. Two shows.
People can't stop visualizing us
together.
We must have
really good chemistry.
We should probably meet
and get to know each other.
It was super funny whenever
I shot with her this year,
because both times
it was of a sexual nature
and a romantic nature.
And it was so funny because
you forget that not everyone
in the crew knows
what's going on.
You know, the writers knew
and the producers knew that
that was my wife,
but a lot of the crew didn't.
And so we're, like, you know,
making out in a bar
and going into the bathroom
to hook up, and in between,
you know, I hadn't seen her
in a while
'cause I was in California,
shooting.
And so the two of us were,
like, very affectionate.
I mean, we weren't,
like, tonguing each other,
but we were just, like,
you know, being cozy
and talking in little whispers
and everything.
And then I'd look around and
people are like, "It's 2021.
Like, Paula needs to cool it on
the special guests on the show.
Like, just meet her outside
the production, you know?"